it was completely unexpected and of
course very disappointing to see the
attack on scientists and on science
and it's continued in fact it's got
stronger in this conversation you're
going to hear about covert the wuhan lab
leak theory attacks on scientists and
how we're going to get out of this
[Music]
unimaginable loss
eye contact only
longing for touch
push back
the extraordinary becoming the ordinary
covid has changed everything and we
still know so little about it
hello and welcome
my guest this week is the world health
organisation's chief scientist dr samia
swaminathan thank you for joining us
yes thank you very much for having me on
your show
the world health organization was
founded to guide global public health
policy in 1948. you're the chief
scientist what a time to be the chief
scientist i wanted to start by asking
you
about the politicization of science and
scientists how have you found that have
you been surprised by it during the
pandemic in fact that was one of the
things i was most surprised by it was
completely unexpected
and of course very disappointing to see
the attack on scientists and on science
and it's continued in fact it's got
stronger over the course of the pandemic
and um
well i think it has the potential to do
a lot of damage
and it's it's one of the areas that i
think we'll have to think very seriously
about
going forward not just dealing with the
pandemic
but in general
when we're trying to educate people
and for them to have you know more
evidence and data-driven
policies for countries i think that the
element
of this kind of mistrust
and and actual
disinformation will need to be addressed
and we need to work with social
scientists behavioral scientists um and
as well as with communities to really
understand this whole phenomenon and
particularly young people i think we
really need to work with young people to
improve scientific literacy health
literacy get them to think more
rationally to question
uh information they see which you know
just comes out of the blue and doesn't
seem to be logical so the who's actually
launched a big program of work in this
area that we call infodemic management
that's really looking into the root
causes encouraging more research it's a
very multi-disciplinary area of work but
certainly one of the challenges have you
have you personally faced attacks i have
you know and i've faced attacks for
just ordinary things which i thought are
you know should be non-controversial so
making statements that are based on the
available evidence and facts of that
time and of course we have to change and
evolve as as data has been coming in and
that's again i think being one of the
things of the pandemic is that we've had
to change and adapt our guidance
as we go along and perhaps that confuses
people who don't understand how science
works and they may think that you were
wrong
to say that a few months ago or that you
don't know what you're talking about so
i think explaining also the process of
science
and that it's a it's a continuous
learning continuous evolution continuous
questioning and as more data comes in we
must change yes i mean
in terms of the attacks on you as as
information has changed how have they
come to you is it mainly been via social
media could you give me a flavor of that
it's mainly been through social media
and i think again this is the first
pandemic i think in the social media age
and so i've seen both the positives and
the negatives the positives of course
have been that you can get your
messaging across that you get a lot of
information from uh the social media
that you can be updated you know
practically in real time to what's
happening around the world the downside
is that you also get a lot of false
information out there and then you get
these communities of people
who organize themselves to attack and
that's what happened to me i was
attacked on social media by a group of
people for whatever the in their vested
interest was i don't know what it is but
they genuinely believed that i was
misinforming whereas i was communicating
the who guidance based on uh all of the
data that we look at do you get very
frustrated by that you know you're one
of the world's top scientists and you're
being accused of lying i mean when you
go home at night
do you do you vent do you get angry
what's your reaction to that it must be
it must be frustrating to say the least
it is very frustrating and uh you know
as i said i was extremely surprised and
very disappointed yes i mean of course
and that is the the wider focus you say
of course it's because of social media i
think what you mean by that is that's
the way they can get in touch with you
of course as well as reading other
information but but who do you blame for
the politicization
of scientists and science i think it's a
combination of factors i think it's the
first time that science has played out
on the front pages of newspapers so in
general people are not used to i mean
when was the last time that vaccine
development was discussed by lay people
you know
there are hundreds of childhood vaccines
and other vaccines that have been
developed and used we've never gone step
by step day by day into looking at these
things so i think one is the
understanding of the process of science
you know understanding about
transmission all our understanding about
the virus has evolved and as that's
evolved our communication has changed
our messaging has changed i think that's
the first thing the second i think is
the issue that you brought up is about
the environment of of
trust
and you can see differences between
countries in how much populations and
communities trust their leaders and
their governments and how well
governments have communicated their
messages how transparent they've been
how they've explained it
let's talk a bit more about the world
health organization then and trust
levels
a key question
i bet you get asked this all the time
how did covert start what is your
understanding as the chief scientist of
the world health organization
so from
you know
historical experience we
we've seen that many
or most viral infections that newly
emerge have been zoonotic infections so
they've come
from an animal host either directly or
through an intermediate
host to infect humans and you know
starting from hiv from the zika
virus from ebola
from of course sars and mers
the other two major viruses that have
infected humans
we've seen that they emerge from an
animal and then sometimes through an
intermediate
host so in this case i think the genetic
sequences of this virus were are still
pointing towards an origin perhaps from
bats that's that's the closest homology
that we found in sequence bats have a
lot of corona viruses and so there's
about 96 97 percent similarity but i
think what we haven't got
is the exact
how when and where
did that jump happen from animals to
humans and that's important to
understand in order to prevent future
pandemics do you not think it's a bit
odd that we don't yet know it's not that
odd because even in the past it's taken
many years actually to understand the
origin of uh
of viruses it takes it takes several
years to to know that sars came from
civic cats and mers was spread from
camels uh and similarly for hiv it took
a long time to understand that it came
from chimpanzees in um
africa and and the chimpanzee viruses
then you know were able to infect humans
and changed if i may just intervene at
that point you know of course it's
important to bring up
the idea the lab theory where there's
this concern that it's been leaked from
a lab by accident or not in china with
scientists working in wuhan joe biden
has asked us intelligence to look into
this u.s intelligence now believe the
virus escaping from a lab is at least
credible have you ruled that out at the
who nothing has been ruled out you know
as you know we've had this group of
scientists an independent international
group of scientists that have been
working on this they've made
two visits to china the last one was in
february of last year there was a very
detailed
report that was presented with several
options and clearly lab
leaks can happen have happened in the
past and one you know cannot rule it out
so one what one needs is to look at the
weight of the evidence and the
scientists who went to china and worked
with local chinese researchers
felt that the most likely scenario was
the zoonotic the the animal that it's
come from an animal now whether it's a
wild animal a domesticated wild animal
or a domestic animal but you know is it
a bird or a bat that we still we don't
know but but
the scientists the majority of them felt
that that was origin but they didn't
rule anything out they had it on the on
the list of hypotheses and said we need
to examine all the data
and do more studies in the field
in china
you brought up the word trust and world
health organization
last year in august the uk sunday times
newspaper published a damning
investigation into what they called
china's power grab of the world health
organization the key allegations amongst
that centered around the idea that
having been embarrassed by the sars
outbreak and the world health
organization's very public criticism of
china over that that officials from
china ever since have done as much as
they can to have as much control at the
who as the chief scientist of the who
what do you make of that allegation i
can tell you that there's no truth
behind those allegations the world
health organization first of all is made
up of its 194 member states and we are
governed in fact we have
now going on in the building behind me
the executive board
where the of course the executive board
consists of 34 of the
member states that that rotate
they are the ones who make policy they
determine the way that who works they
set our priorities they agree on our
funding and we then
you know follow the the program of work
that's set out we also another thing
that's important to understand is who
works through global networks of
scientists and so we have thousands and
thousands of scientists and researchers
and doctors from around the world who
serve on our different committees and
they provide the recommendations that go
into our guidelines so it's not just a
group of people in geneva who can be
influenced by by any country so we try
to be as open and transparent so you
feel satisfied that there hasn't been
any undue influence by the chinese
authorities over the wha because another
reason i ask is you mentioned that
fact-finding mission to china and i
think this is very important about
trusting the who and continuing to have
trust in it as an institution peter ben
barrack a danish scientist who led that
fact-finding mission for the who into
the origins of covert in china said the
team was put under pressure by chinese
scientists who made up half of the
investigating team he told journalists
in august 2021 that those chinese
scientists did not want the lab leak
theory mentioned at all in the report
now i must mention he then retracted
that statement saying it had been
mistranslated but he refused to comment
further the issue is that doesn't help
with this perception that has built up
with some that the who is too close to
china and hasn't been able to trust what
it's been told in china so you know
we've said from the beginning and this
is why it's important for countries now
that are going to negotiate a pandemic
treaty right the special world health
assembly that was held on the 1st of
december came up with this report called
a world together which is really looking
at the future and how do we want it i
mean things could have gone
much better and what we need is for
countries to cooperate now tomorrow
there may be a new outbreak an emergency
in some other country right we don't
want the same thing to be playing out
over and over again so
the world needs to come together the the
member states of the of the who the 194
member states need to come together to
agree on a set of rules it's not who
that can make the rules they need to
make the rules to give powers to who to
do the kind of investigations that will
benefit everyone so those are the kind
of discussions that will happen that
sounds sorry if i may that sounds like
you don't think you've been able to do
the investigations you can a slightly
different question is do you think china
has been open enough this time around
with the doubt it's about the powers
that who has it's about the power so we
work with countries in a collaborative
manner so you need more power yes i
think more power especially to
investigate outbreaks that could lead to
pandemics
certainly do you think the who
has been the leader it could have been
at this time there's also been some
criticism coming away from the china
side
for not declaring a global health
emergency until the 31st of january i
believe in 2020. some people saying it's
been too slow too cautious not muscular
enough in fact almost too collaborative
to move to be a leader at this time
well you can always
in retrospect i think
think that things could have been done
differently or things could have been
done better but the fact is that when a
public health emergency of international
concern was declared there were less
than 100 cases
of sarco v2 infection outside of china
and no deaths had occurred and again i
come back it's the emergency committee
that advises the director general whose
recommendations the dg then follows so
when they first met on the 23rd of
january they
the majority felt that it was not time
to declare a public health emergency of
international concern and then the dg
convened them again a week later and
that at that point they said well it
looks like it is spreading outside china
and they then made the recommendation so
again it's it's a group of scientists
who looked at the data that was
available at that time and made the
recommendation to the dg after that
recommendation was made the announcement
on the 30th of january very few
countries took it seriously
most countries just went about you know
the normal nobody was preparing for what
happened later a few weeks later in in
europe and then in the us because at
that time
yes so
valuable time was lost between the time
that the public health emergency was
declared and cases started climbing in
in many of the western countries so even
though that was the highest level of
alert that who can make just as i'm
asking you about the start of the
pandemic and the declaration of it i
think a lot of people want to hear about
the end of it you know they want to know
when will we know
it's over or certainly at a point where
you can say we're not at a we're not in
a global pandemic what is that point
so i don't think anybody can predict
when
that point will come what we're looking
at scenarios and the scenario that we
hope will play out will be that in 2022
we will have enough people vaccinated
around the world to have that wall of
immunity and we know now that the
vaccines we have currently are very good
at preventing severe disease and death
and so if we can build that immunity
which i have to remind everyone that 3
billion people around the world still
haven't had their first dose of vaccine
i mean that's shocking even though we've
had almost 10 billion doses administered
worldwide it could either circulate at a
low level
infect people some people get ill but
not a lot of people get severely ill it
could also like influenza have seasonal
peaks in the future
or there's a bad scenario as well that
we might get
another variant after omicron that is
not
the mild variant but we could get a
variant that's as transmissible or more
than omicron but also is more virulent
or more deadly we can't rule that out
and that's why we were saying let's not
declare the pandemic over as some people
are doing now it would be foolish
to drop all
our
precautions that we've been taking all
of this time we need to continue that
and hopefully by the end of 2022 we'll
be in a much better position because
let's remember this is a pandemic so one
country cannot
do something without
thinking that they won't be affected by
what goes on in another part of the
world a variant can arise anywhere and
come back and and you know you're back
to square one so i think it's good if
the whole world moves together
we still need to be cautious but it's
too early to declare the pandemic over
you just mentioned of course the
billions of people who don't even have a
first dose in their body of the vaccine
what do you put that down to is it the
situation with patents is it the
situation with countries richer
countries hogging vaccines what is the
block there well in one phrase if you
have to describe its vaccine inequity
vaccine nationalism
you know it's it's a combination of the
things you said i think you know the
beginning obviously vaccines were in
short supply you know they were limited
uh and it's incredible actually that
vaccines even got developed in a year
and that we've had billions of doses
produced if those hundreds of millions
of doses we had in 2021 had been
distributed
equitably the way that the who had laid
out the framework let's protect all the
vulnerable people around the world first
doesn't matter where they live so we can
reduce deaths and then we can start
vaccinating the other age groups coming
down you know to adults and adolescents
and so on then maybe we would not
be seeing new variants now maybe we
would not be still seeing 50 000 deaths
a week
today do you think that the the west the
richer countries hogging vaccines has
led to the variance
yes i think we can say that 85 of people
in africa have not received their first
dose this is a recipe for letting new
variants
develop because the virus is
transmitting unchecked and so i hope in
2022 that we can focus on
bridging that gap have you had covert
yes i have how was that when when was
that in the pandemic if you don't mind
me asking it was quite recent and
it was uh
i was lucky that it was relatively mild
and i could isolate at home and
self-monitor myself and i felt better in
about a week okay because of course so
many more people now have had the the
experience i just thought to ask you i
suppose how it was for you having been
working so hard on this yes i must say
that it was
worrying because one knows so much about
the paths that covet can take the
complications that you can have and also
the possibility of long covert
so i think having been
vaccinated
really did protect me of course i was
taking all the other precautions but
still you know sometimes
the virus still gets to you and
i had yes mild mild symptoms i should
say and i was i kept working throughout
actually even in in isolation i was able
to do that okay well i mean that's good
to hear we wouldn't want to hear it any
other way but i suppose it's just when
you work on something and then you
experience it it can change your view
and also your your kind of understanding
and your empathy levels with it and of
course the reason this has become you
know so real to so many is because now
more and more people sadly know people
who've suffered very badly with it or
sometimes in the worst case lost loved
ones has that happened in your life at
all have you lost anyone's covered
indeed i mean i think during the delta
wave
that happened
across the world and in india last year
i lost many dear friends classmates um
and family members to cover yes so it
did impact me also personally i'm very
sorry to hear that it's it's it's just i
suppose the reality we can talk all
about the politics we can talk all about
the science the lockdowns but at the end
of the day it's um it's just for other
people who i suppose haven't had any
exposure to the science like you say we
never used to talk about epidemiology we
never used to talk about vaccines and
then it just became so real and and how
we get our heads around that
psychologically it's been very very
difficult for people and i imagine at
the same time as working on it you've
experienced that exactly you know i
think so many of my colleagues have been
working around the clock as well we have
to remember the healthcare workers of
course who put themselves you know and
that's why i said my classmates doctors
have uh have died during this pandemic
close friends
um and of course people at who and all
the other public health agencies in the
ministries of health so it's had huge
mental health impacts on both on people
who've been working and seeing a lot of
suffering on the front line but of
course also families you know
young people in in particular so i think
as
we think about coming out of this
pandemic we have to focus not just on
the health impacts of covet and what we
need to do to build health system
resilience but on the broader economy on
inequalities in our society which have
really come to the fore i mean it's for
me
seeing some children that have been out
of school for the last almost two years
now
um i really worry about their future
particularly poor children who have not
had access to online education and
whether they'll be you know into child
trafficking or early marriages
and and so on so those are the kind of
things i hope that countries will think
about thinking about the most vulnerable
and and how to protect them and how to
build
social safety nets in the future
do you think we'll ever get over this of
course we can get through it and
hopefully get around it in some ways but
those ramifications we're only just
starting to think about aren't we the
social educational the impact on this
generation coming through we will come
through it we will get out of it but i
think it will take longer than people
are
currently planning you know people think
will be out of the pandemic by the end
of this year yes i mean the health
impacts of covet hopefully we will get
over it we're not going to get to the
virus we will learn how to live with it
like with other respiratory viruses but
it's the other impacts on the economy on
society and particularly on the
vulnerable this is the time to really
start planning and i particularly hope
that we can keep children at the center
of this rebuilding and the other thing
is not thinking about going back to 2000
how we lived in 2019 but to imagine a
new future where we will continue to be
very
cautious and and sort of
looking at to see whether there are new
variants or viruses emerging i think
we'll have much better surveillance
systems globally as a result of this
pandemic and we can also put our masks
on we know that even if you've had an
ordinary respiratory infection or a flu
it's good to keep your mask on because
at least you're not infecting your
family and co-workers so i think we've
learned a lot we should take into the
future thank you so much for for talking
to us i think that's a very powerful
point to to bring our conversation to a
close on with regards to how we might
not go back but there may be learnings
from this time to to take forward and
thank you for sharing the benefit of
your research with us
thank you
thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again stay safe and
goodbye
[Music]
you